chers amis, nous sommes des cosmonautes de roscosmos
oleg novitsky par dubrov félicitations
avec l'une des vacances les plus importantes
notre patrie
jour de la russie chaque année le sens et
l'importance de cette fête devient pour
nous des êtres chers de plus en plus importants
en accord avec notre sentiment d'âme
patrie sincèrement convaincue que
La Russie est ce qu'il y a de plus cher pour nous tous
place sur terre est tellement plus que
où tu es né où nous vivons
cœur de ressentir une connexion brisée avec
notre histoire avec des valeurs spirituelles et
c'est invisible
mais un fil très fort relie tout
génération notre pays est riche en smart
des personnes talentueuses et motivées
nous pouvons atteindre
et faire des progrès incroyables
faire des découvertes scientifiques
nous créons des chefs-d'œuvre de la culture avec lesquels
le monde entier vous admire avec des vacances
jour de la russie